Jeff D'Andria: Let me see, anything else before I leave that point?
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, we'll talk through some of the things that you might want to get in there. I think it's important to know on the psychology piece, most of these computer science, kind of technical-type recruiters.
Jeff D'Andria: weren't software engineers themselves, you know, so, for instance, personally, when I would go to career fairs around, you know, different states and little parts of Canada, when I had those 2 or 3 engineers with me at a career fair.
Jeff D'Andria: that's when I think my hit rate was the best, because I could literally use them as the filter, and I was like, you guys, talk to the students, you look at the resumes, you put them in the yes stack, maybe stack, no stack, because I trust your opinion way more than me.
Jeff D'Andria: But after that, if you're just applying online, and it probably is just a recruiter with no computer science background, you know, just…
Jeff D'Andria: some… some just things to know that we really, like, want to see in there.
Jeff D'Andria: Well, number one, if you have any previous experience where you've had the title, like software engineer, intern, whatever, that's kind of like the holy grail. Like, it's just so easy to say, yes, that's a slime dunk candidate.
Jeff D'Andria: All good if you don't.
Jeff D'Andria: We'll work on other strategies.
Jeff D'Andria: But other than that, I would say things like…
Jeff D'Andria: times you rose above the pack, you know? Like, if you were in a hackathon, and even better if you got some kind of award at a hackathon, but just that you're at a hackathon at all, right? But anytime you've kind of rose above the pack, maybe like a top 3, or you placed in something, or a selective award.
Jeff D'Andria: Don't just put the award in there. Like, put the context. Was it out of hundreds of students? Was it out of 100?
Jeff D'Andria: you were a top 3, like, build that context in. Those are the kind of things that recruiters are looking for to
Jeff D'Andria: help you be one of the 5 or 10 people, say, that they put in front of a hiring manager. You gotta give us things like that. If you're an achiever, you know, it's easy to sell to a hiring manager if a student, if a candidate… God, look, this person is achieving things. One way to do that, for instance, could be
Jeff D'Andria: See this selected achievements here?
Jeff D'Andria: I've seen this a few times used, where someone just has… literally, I'm just gonna tease out and frame it myself as an achiever, because I'm going to call out the achievements.
Jeff D'Andria: If we don't do that, they're just kind of… you're making me fish throughout the resume for achievements, but we could just frame ourselves that way, right?
Jeff D'Andria: And then I'll say one more, there's so many others, but one for sure is, passion projects.
Jeff D'Andria: I might have mentioned that before, but I've seen that across many… Microsoft and TikTok, personally. Hiring managers, if someone has a passion project on their resume, it almost becomes like an automatic first-round interview.
Jeff D'Andria: So, those are, those are kinds of things that you might want to get, again, in this kind of
Jeff D'Andria: Top third.